[Music]
ah
a new day has come how enthralling
i have so much work to do but i can't
get anything done until i eat my
glorious shiba meal
[Music]
alone again in this vast land oh that's
a new blanket
but i must stay focused on my mission at
hand
shiba oh i crave my delicious savory wet
food
such a shame only my human lump knows
how to snap peel and serve it to me
human darling rise and shine um
i desire more attention why can't he
read my mind
has he forgotten how to love thee oh my
kitten eyes he never says no to those
look how beautiful i am human
human my beauty look at it
i know i'll sing for him
[Music]
this song needs an instrument
i've been practicing the harp
do not get discouraged maybe i'll signal
to humans monstrous pause to serve me
that sweet delicious
shiba okay this is working i can feel it
this has to be working
well aren't you just the most awake
right now human
you're alive of course i am and simply
starving as well
let's get you some breakfast huh
did you like my new song did you hear
that note i hit at the end
i know i'm improving i can feel it
ooh some roasted chicken huh
yeah but of course what else would one
eat for breakfast
you are a hungry little guy aren't you
oh sweet human this smells divine
this is exactly what i want you really
do
love me good night
you are so lucky i love you